so did you hear the one about the
passenger yanked from a Southwest
Airlines flight for making a joke the
flight from Sacramento to Austin Texas
have been delayed for hours which
spurred flight attendants to hand out
water
one passenger asked if it was vodka the
young flight attendant didn't find that
funny and despite fellow passengers
defending the Joker the plane was turned
back
deputies boarded the vessel and it
squirted the guy off well at least he
found a way to get off the plane in time
anyway Southwest serves millions of
passengers so maybe this humorless is an
exception for a company once known for
its irreverence but the incident is no
longer out of the ordinary for life in
general for so many people who came of
age but never grew up in the era of safe
spaces jokes are viewed as actual
offensives offenses aggressions trigger
warnings are encouraged before students
see challenging plays comedy sets are
stopped at one joke hurts one act of his
feelings good comedians avoid colleges
altogether the result we have a
generation that fails to see that humor
is one effective tool in reducing
tension in stressful events like a plane
stuck on a runway or stuck on the five
if humans can no longer see humors value
in reducing hostility what are we left
with hostility
I mean life used to be like this funny
truthful shocking now it's like this
scolding self serious comedian as
schoolmarm
it's the Seth Meyers effect a joke list
life becomes mundane and pale even late
at night yet he still has a show
now that's an unfunny punchline can't do
jokes anymore on the play Dana like
there's like there's a couple things you
can't joke about on a plane right but
everything else should be within the
limits the other other thing is the
Southwest does have pretty great staff
this seems like really weird oh yeah I
think it was I think it was just I think
it's I don't want to be ageist but I
think it's young people all young people
are bad Shannon all young can I say that
legally what yes you can legally do that
but when I look at like one of my
favorite shows of all time the office
yes I feel like you couldn't make that
show now no you can't I mean
manly and all the guys I just feel like
when I see the old episodes that are
maybe let you know that a lot of
Millennials do watch that and they do it
on a loop how are they not passed out
because there is area there's Stephanie
on friends that you go you can't believe
that that's happening maybe we're just
better people now more enlightened one
there were so enlightened we don't need
jokes anymore because I think you know
I'm a big Lenny Bruce fan yeah I like
Richard Pryor and write Redd Foxx so I
think that myself they put some of those
guys in jail back then right so I mean
I'm not sure that we were always full of
humor yeah because I mean the idea there
was to absolutely push the line scour
you know conventional thinking in
America and they would put people in
jail we don't do that but this is so
ridiculous it makes me think Jesse
something else is going on between the
flight attendant and that person oh you
think they had a history I don't know
but maybe you know I was wondering about
that but then I read and I found out
that other people on the plane were just
shocked by this because I was thinking
maybe there was something else going on
but I did from what I'm saying maybe it
was his tone or maybe like you know he
had spilled something on her foot well
tone is important and I would have to
disagree with you about locking people
up for telling jokes
Trump joked that Russia if you're
listening Hillary's emails that was in
the molar report as a potential
obstruction charge that's how seriously
argument especially when the
investigators come out and take it as a
joke but I mean think about okay here's
the big problem you have young people
who have a problem with jokes because
it's to that if it's not funny to them
then it's offensive and that's the tool
that keeps society going it's the
lubrication if you are in a meeting and
you need and let's say meeting between
tribes
I'm sure humor was the tool that kept
you from killing each other and and
that's what scares me but is this even a
bad joke it wasn't an offensive joke
wasn't vaad weave saying like you know
we've been waiting here for a couple
hours let's hope that this is vodka
that's not yet anyway that's the point
there was nothing like she said I don't
find that funny yeah or something like
that so okay fine you tell them to turn
around the plane yeah everybody else
everybody else is furious - that's
definitely jumpy maybe it's two that are
jokes we think are so hilarious and
wonderful we are getting old because I
made a joke about Carmen Miranda
yesterday not 90 night everybody's
looking at me like crickets chirping
that's no one knows who it is yeah
that's she was a dick flamenco dancers
Carmen who you knew in San Diego you
know where the hell it was when when
Trump told yeah yeah but it's not about
it is the fact that we are raising you
know that we don't these are we were
raising children in their safe little
cages so they if they go outside
something like that wasn't just that she
didn't like the joke that she abused her
power and kicked them off that yeah
that's the other thing uniforms I just
hope we don't find out more about this
story and it turns out to be completely
wrong
because I really don't want to do a
correction I handle the corrections on
Jesse there's all my Corrections takes
all the blame that's not funny